okay hello everyone welcome to a wolfram
language design review part of our
incremental language development
uh
series and we have a few topics here and
i think i'm told we should start on the
second one
general operator forms
yeah so this is a discussion from a
little while ago um the idea was that
operator applied and curry applied are
very useful functions but for a lot of
cases we have functions where we want to
make simple operator forms and we don't
want to have dedicated functions for
them
and so the notion was to create either
a
typeset form or an infix form to
generate simple operators
and this was an experiment of looking at
ways to you know this is just a
placeholder operation here obviously
with the up
t arrow
but trying to play around with the idea
of
generating operators with an infix form
wait a second so basically
i'm sorry but i my recollection of is
that we gave up on this idea that we we
ran into
it was a precedence issues and we gave
up um
that was a different discussion that was
talking about lambda function
oh right right right right yes so the
these two started as a similar
conversation um
okay
maybe it's better to though i mean these
are done as in fixed forms presumably if
you had multiple arguments
you'd want to have something like a uh
you know as opposed to in fixed form
maybe it'd be something like you write
the function name and then you know
some sort of star something like that
and then an open bracket and then you
have the
arguments there i don't know uh just by
doing it
basically
the point is all of these things are
sort of pop-up function making
i mean let's take the example i don't
know let's say integrate for example
let's say we want an operator form of
integrate
where you know we say now what that
really is
is i mean here's the operator form it's
hash comma x ampersand
so to speak i mean the operative form is
you feed in the x
and this sort of auto fills
um
and this is what we're trying to it's
it's again it's yet another
well it's a form of pop-up function
creation am i right
yeah that's the essential idea
right so i mean in a sense what we what
we might have is something let's say we
had a prefix operator
just for fun
let's let's imagine i mean because
because what we actually have
is operator applied
what does this do
um so how would i do this integrate
thing with operator applied
let me just be operator applied of
integrate of x
yeah i think you're right
right and then that's
right
okay so
and
right so i guess if we want this this as
an actual infix form right it would need
to have precedence higher than bracket
or you won't be able to just sort of
type it in and bracket which maybe is
fine because all maybe all we need is
symbols on either side of this but
yeah well i mean so so
the type of thing we would have here is
what would we have we would have
integrate
and then we would have something like uh
you know
star let's say
let's say it's at bracket
okay x
i mean i don't i don't know that would
work precedence wise but i mean that's
the type of thing we're talking about
it's an annotation to this
that says this is the this this is
basically
it's an it's a postfix operator
that represents operator replied
am i right
yeah that's the general idea
and then
an alternative form would be something
where there's a subscript to that
operator for example
that allows you to select you know
different argument structures rather
than just this particular case
of you know fill in the first argument
give the second argument so to speak
so i think it would be useful to take
some
you know examples of
functions i don't know what i mean you
know table might be an example i i just
worry that i mean let's say we say table
i mean what would we say we would say
table
see that this is going to get totally
messed up with um
uh
with scoping yeah there's gonna be a
lexical scoping problem there isn't
there
i mean so that's not good go ahead would
we be talking about this if operator
replied had a very short name
like if operator applied had like a you
know
three character name or something i mean
i don't have a proposal but but
you know we wouldn't maybe not
yeah yeah because it'll just be so easy
to write
so maybe the special syntax is is
you know might not be necessary yeah
right so let's say operator applied was
just op or something
which i don't think is right but um
yeah
uh
i kind of agree that that will be just
fine
i mean another weird thing we could do
is we could have a symbol like or like
some sort of weird uh
icon for the head
yeah supposed to you know that it's sort
of similar to the weird icon for an
infix
it is we've never really done that i
mean the only the only cases it's a good
point i mean we have pie
um
but we don't have i mean we and i wonder
whether our lambda thing could be done
that way as well
i wonder whether that would save us from
um
i mean you know it would just be
uh and it's kind of amusing we could
imagine something
where we say
uh rather than function just for fun
we have some kind of you know lambda
x
blah blah blah
just as a a decorative thing in there
the only problem is in that case you
probably have to have a special lambo a
special lambda yeah no no
special lambda yes
um
so an interesting question is could we
invent an icon
that would be
uh indicative of what this means
like for example could we make something
which has some kind of multi-slot
you know some look that has um
uh what's a good example let's let's
just make um
ah what do i do here i say new canvas
and then i say
so another feature i mean if this
actually worked i mean another thing
that would be nice is if it would be
sort of
it would actually be some sort of
ligature
like maybe well i don't know it would be
nice if you could if you could type it
using some weird string of
of slashes and stars and stuff because
then it also means that a text setter
you could write it
but i mean you could write some weird
slashes and stars and have it turn into
something
fairly different well right i mean it
would have
right it would have a long name whatever
it's however it's displayed right so we
you know you could always type in that
long name well ultimately you could type
an operator applied
right yes that's true well but you know
you'd have something that would
you know
in a in in the front end would look like
the the thing you're going for but
so okay so the question here is
is there a if we had iconography i mean
and
you know yes it would be some kind of
weird you know bracket star
you know something like that for example
and then we represent that as some kind
of visual thing
and then
we say our integrate here
of x
i mean is this like just irreducibly
obscure
i think it depends on whether you wrote
it like that it would be pretty obscure
but yeah
well i mean so the question is what's
that icon whether is there an icon
that indicates
that can reasonably indicate
do we have anybody from design here for
any other reason
uh not at the moment
yeah go ahead
crystal so what what was the
i mean for the infix did anyone have
ideas for what the infix would look like
or just was the idea just that there
could be an infects yeah i mean at the
at the moment when we discussed it it
was just the idea that we could have an
infix form we didn't have a specific
visual in mind
and what about something like a template
box like escape grad space escape works
escape what
escape grad escape
grid yeah
and then you have the the two places to
place the function and the argument you
want to
carry
i had no idea that was the way that grad
worked i didn't know what i mean
i mean that's interesting because we
could do the same thing with with um
uh you know we could do that
not with this but but we could do that
with a lambda as well
you know if we had f l for a lambda for
a function lambda
you know let's say we had a thing called
function lambda
we could do exactly the same thing
could we not
and we wouldn't even have precedent
sincerity would we
because we could do whatever precedence
we want in this case so in other words
this will be a solution to making our
thing look like a lambda function
am i correct
perhaps
i'm sorry you're talking about it doing
something like escape del dot
or or i guess you did escape grad there
yeah i did i'm suggesting escape fl
makes a function lambda
which you know it makes a character
function lambda where what it does is
it's lambda sub x
of
x squared for example or whatever it is
oh
how does this work with precedence for
that
how does that do
so
each slot is a self-contained unit so
um
i'm a bit surprised you're not seeing
any highlighting is that 13 1 because
because i was pretty sure that i turned
on highlighting so when you're in there
you see
that you know which slot you're in so
you know whether you're inside or
outside of the
right yeah you want the list if you
wanted to actually evaluate in the
subscript
all right
but for the the non-subscript part the
part that's written after the the dell
and so on is it
like is that inside of some some little
box and like if you press right on your
cursor you'll exit the box without the
cursor visually moving or something or
correct and they're they're supposed to
be highlighting background highlighting
so you know whether you're inside or
outside it should be
and i don't know why
it's not there because it was there when
i added it and i tested it so okay so
that's a bug so we need to track it down
so avery that's for you to go chase
yep
the
um
stephen you need a vector in the
subscript to make this work
okay so it got this is really nice i
mean this would give us this lambda
thing
exactly what we need because because it
has this box
and i don't know what the visual
appearance of it should be and whether
it should have a little dotted box
around it
which i argue it might i mean you're
saying even in generic input that this
would have a background color or
not it would be
when you are inside of the box
there should be sort of like an instance
just like with an inline cell you get
this shading when you enter the inline
cell there should be similar
i'm not sure that there shouldn't be
some kind of hint
of um
uh
oh
oh hold on i think i think i may have
just lied to you
um right so that yeah what that inserts
is not a template box those are just
sort of raw boxes but we could the if
right if you if you took um
right if you did hold of that and then
looked at the output which will be a
true template box
that'll have to be okay but i'm saying
this should have some kind of
highlighting or or indicator of scope
here
this is not right that it doesn't do
that and possibly it should even have
one
you know that survives here in the input
right that actually indicates that these
this is parenthesized off
by making sense
right well so
right what i'm saying is i i was i i'm
i misremembered what uh
this escape sequence does it does not
insert a template box it just puts in
the raw thing so there
it has sort of normal
precedence things so if you did like a
plus two now
it would
you know
well i guess or plus x
uh right you got that right it added two
to everything
um
right so it's the first thing yeah
that's wrong i mean that's wrong that
has that doesn't have the the
i don't even understand the precedence
here so you're saying
okay there's a precedence issue but but
what we're saying is you could have a
template box that will properly delimit
its second argument
yes
okay and i'm saying i think we should
consider doing that for this function
lambda thing
okay but that that does not address the
question
of the
um
of the operator applied form
i don't know i mean it's sort of an
interesting idea
as christopher says it's a pity that
operator replied is such a long name
okay if we were going to make an icon
for operator applied what would it look
like
first of all would this be a subscript
wait
i think that being well that being a
subscript is too weird that defeats kind
of the point of it doesn't it
maybe so but i mean by the time we were
going to jose's mechanism here it might
as well be a subscript
okay what could we draw iconographically
here what does this represent
this is saying
you know so what we have here is
by the way what is this what is this
pipe operator thing
so this was something from one of our
customers who
saw us discussing this previously and
mentioned there's a pipe operator in r
that works in a similar fashion it's a
little different than operator applied
but the general idea being that you can
pipe data into functions
effectively creating an operator form
but
more or less in reverse
so the argument structure is reversed
where you have data piped into function
and it gets us
inserted into
typically the first argument
okay so hold on so what that is is a
thing where you're saying
okay so let's just understand this
because this is kind of an interesting
idea actually so you're saying
you're saying with this
this is
data
this thing
function
operator form a function effectively
yeah but the problem is that that's not
an operator
is this like slash slash operator form
but it isn't because because this thing
it implicitly functionifies this yeah
right so what this is doing is it's
saying if if i have f of x here
what this is doing
is or f of f of u or something what
that's turning into is f of data comma u
correct
so this thing
could be a sin in this model which i
think is a little bit crazy
this could be a syntactically totally
squas
you know scrambled object
because in our case
yeah i feel like part of the advantages
i mean one of the advantages of operator
forms is just this sort of
style of writing where you sort of have
a chain of sort of pipeline style
but but i think the other advantage is
that there are lots of places where you
want to be able to have one of these
functions and manipulate it you know put
it in the first argument of map and then
put it you know etc etc and so i think
having something where this is not
really operator applied it's just sort
of another syntax for function
application
um
which i think is maybe not
you know it's a different thing it's
it's a look this is a a syntax
like there there's no there are no
there are no curried functions involved
right it's just a syntax for doing
function application
well it's implicitly
doing some kind of weird not really
currying but it look what it's doing is
it's taking
you know what it's this to write it out
it is data and then we've got
um
uh what is it i can't think about it
it's it's this thing here is implicitly
created
and then how do i do that with the at
star or slash star is there any way to
do that how do i do that
if i do this what does that do
i'm not sure if the precedence is right
what the heck should that do well it
should be inert because it's just you
haven't actually applied it to anything
are you thinking of slash slash
maybe i am thinking of slash slash
right
otherwise known as the difference
between function application and
composition which is similar to the
issue here this this is this you don't i
don't actually need the parentheses in
this particular case right
right
that's the difference between the arrow
and operator applies the arrow is
actually doing the application
evaluating as opposed to producing a
function that you can manipulate
right so what this is doing
i mean
look what's happening here is that we've
got an implicit
i mean
i've got another question about about
yet another form of function
okay although i agree that this is
getting a little silly
but let's imagine that you could type
something like this
and that this is
a function that is merely in the
brackets argument list
did that make any sense so i mean a
locally syntactically local form of
function
i think we discussed this even with the
dot last time
or maybe not last time but a while ago
yeah well okay is it crazy i mean so but
i think i hadn't really internalized the
idea that it will be purely i.e
it is
you know it it's reminiscent of nothing
okay i e it is just
okay
um hit look for example um
you know insert here
comma u
it is just
a top level element
of a
um
of an explicit
bracket bracket
function
so so two questions the first question
is
is the basic point of this to save the
one character that is an ampersand
and the second question is what it what
about g of h of q of f of insert here
of
two
if that makes sense like what if the
insert here is deeply buried in the head
no then then it doesn't do it just like
nothing doesn't work in that case
this is very bizarre and
on
right this is unstable and very
counterintuitive nothing isn't unstable
no but that that's because nothing is
nothing and this is not nothing
i think this is like
well well nothing right
i mean
some might disagree about whether or not
nothing is unstable but even if we were
to concede that point that's only not
unstable because it will only ever fire
inside of list unless you manually tell
it to fire inside of other things
right but what i'm suggesting is perhaps
a bad idea but what i'm suggesting is
that okay so let's take our our
our integrate example what i'm
suggesting is that you would write this
integrate this comma x of x squared
right the problem is that i think that
this is basically just
you know it's saving a single character
over normal pure functions at the
expense of
well one adding another syntax for doing
functions which i think would be kind of
confusing but also the fact that it's
going to be so brittle and it's going to
break in so many different situations
and you're going to write something like
this and then you're going to modify it
and now it's going to stop working
because you added an extra level of
function around the integrate and it
won't be obvious why that's a problem
etcetera etcetera i see what you're
saying i see what you're saying you're
saying the head
that in the head case like this
that it then wouldn't work
yeah i mean just stuff like that where
it's not really
like it's just it's never made clear
where the pure function is
and so it can only ever work in some
really restricted case and i think it's
just going to lead to so many weird
problems however i mean this does lead
me to one kind of syntactic beauty type
thing which is maybe there should be an
alternative appearance for hash i mean
or alternatively we could just make hash
as a ligature i mean i've wanted this
for ages actually
make hash as a ligature not
look
i mean this whole thing just looks so
obscure
what if we ligatured this to something a
little nicer like for example one thing
i've wanted with this
is to make it much more like a um
uh
you know much more like a placeholder
box with a few little tentacles on it
i think that would really help i mean i
think that that would make our functions
just look it's kind of obvious what's
going on then whereas if you see a hash
sign it's like i don't know what the
heck that is
i think for example
right but what about what but what about
pound pound pound foo pound 17.
we could we could deal with all of those
i mean like for example
um you know hash foo we could imagine
putting that inside
which would be rather nice
i mean this one is rather easy as well
this one is just two boxes next to each
other
i mean now that we have programming
literatures we can do stuff like this
i i really rather like this so maybe we
could
can somebody see if jeremy happens to be
available
i can do that
but while you're doing that can you do
me a favor and go back to where you had
the grad
yes and select it and do shift command
in
let me make another one
why did that happen is it because those
are
placeholders
oh yeah
okay
yeah
so now it has
only when i click
no only when i click inside that
placeholder
yep
right so now it right so now if you did
x squared plus 2x
then
it would you know list xy and then x
squared plus 2x you would know
you know where you were
yeah
right
yeah it's good
that's nice why didn't it do it on
initial input
because that
keyboard shortcut was created well
before we had that capability and
template box so it create puts in so
it's just putting in a subscript a
literal subscript and some placeholders
that's worth thinking about
okay
all right but anyway
in um
uh
okay
going back to this
if we wanted to beautify ampersand i
mean i think we've talked about this
before
and i bet we could make something that
is more like a you know an opening mouth
type thing that has the same basic
structure as an ampersand but it's just
more obviously like applying a function
see what i'm saying
right so i mean
let me well well the slots be
the ligatured like this even if there's
no ampersand
i would assume yes
okay
and then i mean my main concern is if if
we get too fancy with this right how
will people ever know what to type in i
agree but that's been an issue with with
dash greater than for millions of years
and i've been surprised at how little of
an issue that's actually been
i thought that would be a killer and i
was thinking you know in documentation
we should always show it as dash greater
than and so on but that's been
surprisingly not such a problem
but i agree it's got to have some
indication of you know what it is but i
i don't think it needs to be i mean like
what i was imagining here was
is that why in documentation notebooks i
think dash greater than doesn't look at
your eyes
is that intentional yeah yeah that was
intense yes
oh my god okay i was always i thought
there was a bug for like years
well it may be wrong i mean it might be
the wrong thing right
right we certainly can't turn on auto
ligatures because of all the
documentation that tells you how to type
things in right right so
we certainly couldn't turn on auto
ligatures before we updated all of those
instructions to
not auto ligature right because it would
be kind of useless to say
type this in to create this symbol if
you just see the same symbol in both
places
where am i looking i was looking for a
partial bow tie
a bow tie with one side missing
uh that's under the
equals i think tab near the bottom
i'm not seeing any bow ties here at all
it's gone informal
special character well i mean it's kind
of okay let's use this one just doesn't
have that but i mean it's not really
what i had in mind but
but i mean that that that's not really
what i had in mind but what i was
thinking about was something where
it's kind of like
um
you know where it's sort of an opening
on that side
hey jeremy we're talking about
beautifying
it's an old topic we're talking about
beautifying functions and we're talking
about
uh as a ligature type thing
replacing hash signs by
squares with little tentacles on them
and replacing the ampersand by something
that looks more like
a a thing that is kind of like a bit you
know it uses the fact that in an
ampersand there's kind of that opening
on the right hand side
to make something which looks like it is
a a thing where this is
like trying to
eat something if that makes any sense
jeremy here
did i just
no i'm on mute sorry about that no no
the concern is are you worried about
people's ability to type this right
with other characters
but there might be ways to handle that
for example for example one thing we
haven't thought about is we have an
increasing number of hover effects
and we could imagine something which
says you know which hovers and says rule
or function or something paren and then
how to type it
yeah
but you just look at code and
just have to weigh how foreign it's
going to look and
i know but but like for example the big
win along these lines has been dash
greater than yeah yeah
because people don't get confused by
that and yet it really makes code look a
lot nicer and i mean you know and now
we've got also the function thing which
i use with some frequency
um
i mean look the other case that that
maybe is a story
okay here's a question um
this is something that i
you know this form
like for example in the ewl book i don't
really talk about this form yet i'm kind
of beginning to think that that form is
a better version of map or for each or
whatever you might call it
um
and i mean the the
no there's probably nothing there that
it has to have almost as much syntax as
this doesn't it because it has to have
the variable as well
i mean in other words
look
you know what we've got right now is map
function
x f of x
and then we can apply that
to abc
and we get that
but now the question is is there any way
of minimizing this
like like for example we might have
something which says
i mean okay we could imagine i know this
is a good idea but like something like
you know map function x f of x and then
this
is that useful or interesting
just it's such a common thing
to want to
and and this seems like a rather
backwards syntax for this
this making any sense to anybody i mean
anybody think this is a good idea does
everybody think it's a bad idea
everybody
but i i'm i think i'm mostly confused at
this point what is the idea that you're
asking about
okay the concept function together
basically right it's fun it's map where
you don't have to write
the ampersand
i think like look you can you can do
this in fewer characters by writing the
operator form of map it's just map of f
hash ampersand
is the same as your map function there i
know i know
and it's more readable and it's less
obscure
and in fact it's even simpler because
it's just map of f
i know that i know that
but i mean okay if we had this be
this slightly more
you know box-like thing which i i
thought i had suggested ages ago and i
don't know why it never happened
jeremy you know you know what i'm
talking about i i do i remember that
yeah why do we never do that
we should do it
do it and similarly here we should
stylize the ampersand in some way so
that it looks like a sort of attachment
device
which it doesn't look like right now it
just looks like an ampersand but i'm
sure there's a way to distort the
ampersand so you're kind of you know so
those pieces are like uh you know it's
like an attachment thing like like for
example i don't know if you i bet if you
pull an ampersand into into you know
photoshop or something you can you could
easily make it so that you just pull up
pull its little pincers up
am i making sense you take these two
parts
and you pull the pincer part up to the
middle
so that it's more symmetrical and i
think it's still going to look like an
ampersand but it's going to look like a
stylized ampersand which also looks like
something that can eat a function
argument
did that make sense it does i'm kind of
sketchy on paper now
it had to be really distorted
yeah i'll offer the following
possibly pointless comment but in a
sense right this is this is an
anti-ligature right because presumably
when somebody types in ampersand
ampersand for and
we'd want normal-looking ampersands not
this
modified ampersand
yes
yes i mean i
okay so i was i was just um
yes that's right but i mean so in that
sense it's an anti-ligature
so
okay so what i was thinking here
so we're always talking ligatures we
could look at you know i think there's
some things like
like i think [ __ ] the proof assistant
has uh
if i remember right they have like crazy
ligatures like things like double
ampersand turns into a conjunction sign
stuff like that
like you know everything turns into some
weird symbol
um
does it work is it really horrifying i
mean i haven't used it enough to know i
i know that it looks kind of funky
because you have all these these unicode
characters you know but but uh
i i don't know if it actually uh
if it's too confusing for people
yeah well the thing i just do doesn't
work but but um
i think in general though i mean
the ampersand is a totally random symbol
to use for this so
it's sort of uh doesn't
i know it's maybe tragic just
distort it yeah yeah right so maybe we
can make it into something which makes
it seem like it makes more sense
um
and we have a version of ampersand for a
hold function too
what do you mean it's like
i find it pretty useful to use like how
to put attribute hold to a function
right you have to write a function
as a symbol
and i use it pretty often
but you're saying function x f of x hold
yeah that case
hold all yeah
hold complete
right because you got to pick one of
those
yeah
and maybe like
some ampersand versions for those
can be useful
well i mean if we're going to unicode
ampersands
then
um
okay actually the ethan is commenting
here what about a special paren
to signify a function i don't think that
quite works because the problem is
it needs to be a ternary you know you
can't let's say let's say we had you
know whatever it is you know something
like this well it's not going to work or
whatever
let's say we were just using this
you've still got to have this and this
and then the f of x
actually i think i remember
wait a minute we talked about this like
a few weeks ago like a month ago or
something when we were having a very
similar discussion and one of the ideas
was to have a function notation
that was stylized brackets it was like
you know bracket
vertical bar
you know for the open and vertical bar
bracket for the close or something like
that and the point was
you know that way you could actually
you'd actually indicate the scope
unlike with uh ampersand
so you'd say that of x or of you know
whatever you want
but not even that like that that's
something much weirder you've just
written there are two things you could
do so the first thing is just to have
you know bracket vertical bar f of hash
bracket vertically whatever
f
i'm just making up uh a bracket thing
but some styles bracket and that would
be equivalent to f of hash ampersand
i should make the scoping more clear and
alternatively if you did want to support
some two argument thing you would of
course have a comma in the middle so you
could have you know
bracket vertical bar x comma f of x
that's interesting because it is true
that that's the problem that we have in
all of the right-hand sides of options
and all those kinds of things it's a
precedence problem which would not
happen if it was match fix
yes
we we talked about this though before in
another and another ifd meeting or
something
um nick do you know
yeah that's what we that's what we
that's the conversation i was
uh referencing at the start of this
discussion i said didn't we did conclude
that uh all right so let's enumerate
let's enumerate the issues here okay
let's just enumerate what we're talking
about
so we have got
uh possibilities oops i don't want to
use that possibilities
okay we've got beautify
hash and ampersand that seems like a
thing worth exploring regardless of any
of these other things
um another possibility is uh
oh yeah then there's the function lambda
idea
like grad which i think also is worth
exploring
um
i think
let's see then what else here is worth
exploring we also talked about the
possibility of an of a
of a form for operator applied
which was
i mean
okay so
beautify this
that probably means we don't have to
consider
um
a another possibility here is additional
characters for hash
e.g
eg some kind of you know box type thing
or
this just to make code look nicer
um
that's auto beautify hash
and amazon
okay so then then we've also got the
possibility here
of a match fix
function
and by the way that might be a
convenient way to deal with nick's
issue
because you might be able to do
well i don't know whether that's a okay
there's a separate issue which is
um
uh
special syntax
for held
pure functions
okay so matchfix function
which i think is also worth looking at
because that would that would finally
solve the problem forever
of
you know options and things like this
um okay none of these these are all
possibilities for
function
and now possibilities for operator
applied
which we didn't really address here
except implicitly because if we improve
function operator apply becomes less
important
do you agree
yeah
probably
i think there are still cases where
there's an elegance to using operator
applied but yeah okay well fine but i
mean then then then what we've thought
about for operator applied is a
um you know
uh prefix
single character
pseudo prefix
it's not a prefix it's just another oh i
know i know i know
right it's just like like it's single
character
pseudo prefix
ie
like pi
right in other words it's just turning
into
something equivalent to operator it's
just that there's a there's a thing
that behaves just like operator applied
but we still don't know what that
i mean you know the question is what
does that look like is it something
which has
you know
it's it's
let me break out my apl book
yeah does it it's not sort of where
we're going
yeah that's sort of a joke cause i think
it's a bad thing when you break up the
apl book for syntax suggestions
well that's a good question i mean apr
has a lot of interesting ideas
um
and tax is not a winning one
no i mean many aspects of the syntax
were just hopeless
i'm just looking at an abl
table here
um
oh gosh i remember that one multiplied
by pi
yeah great up and grade down those were
okay
that was crazy
that was
what the heck is that okay
that's um
some of these are just completely
bonkers
i mean these are also rendered in a much
more reasonable way on wikipedia and
they are on book
oh yeah well okay let's look at the
dyadic case because that's um
okay
the value of polynomial
no that's crazy
um
yeah because a lot of these operators
like like the the prefix x glam
is a factorial and the infix x clam is a
binomial
does it does it have ointment this is
this is the stuff right
this is
plus dot times
is its way of doing inner product
right
what is that
right i don't really know okay so i
don't think it has this particular case
does it it doesn't have a way of taking
i think it didn't have because it didn't
have the notion really
of a pure function i think
yeah this looks like
j language uses ampersand as an infix
for carrying
what is that what do you mean as an
infix for currying how does it work
uh
oh it's i don't know really it looks
like it's using it it's like you use a
function on the left
of the ampersand and the argument on
right hand side and you can and this is
indicates
an operator form
wait a minute you do what
you
what do you do
hold on
i'm confused
yeah i found
yeah the only the examples
i can't tell at all what's going on
can you place an example
well i can't even find one that's that
good it's just on the wikipedia page
they you know there are a couple
mentions of ampersands but it's like
totally unclear what they're doing
what's going on it's just like a string
of random characters
because if you want to have a number
this function is going to be like divide
10 percent 2
and then percent is like an infix
oh is it like artilles
like when you do you know tilde join
tilde that's an infix form of joy i
wonder whether there's anything more we
can do with this because
you know i was very proud of this idea
35 years ago
and i do occasionally use it but again
that's another thing which we could
light your eyes better
what's the precedence if you do x tilde
f tilde y tilde z or something
i just have what you already have there
and then add another one
i think it's left right
well if you make an odd num not hold on
but wait a minute it's not
what the heck did that just no it was
left right it was left right but but now
give it an odd number get rid of the z
it'll be a syntax error
okay
although it's a particularly obscure
syntax error because nothing pinks in
the actual input
that's just because only the kernel can
actually
parse these things right as far as the
front end is concerned right this is uh
you know what the user assistant
it should put a carrot here
it should put some kind of red tilde
carrot thing here
it's just wrong
well it may be wrong but
you know it's it uh
you know this would have been done
in 1996 if it were easy to do
okay but i think it should be fed into
the user assistance discussion because i
think it should do something like that
carrot and i would suggest some kind of
tilde with a carrot underneath it a red
tilde with a carrot underneath it or
something a tilde followed by a carrot
or something i mean this is not a common
case because people aren't using the
tilde thing very much
and again again in terms of the let's
make this more elegant now that we have
programming ligatures we could turn the
tilde into a different unicode character
if we wanted to
and i think we should
and jeremy i think that's another thing
for you to try and figure out what can
we make you know
this thing
see we could even make the two tildes
not be exactly the same we could make
them be similar but not exactly the same
for what it's worth
what's the difference what why are they
different
well
because what's happening is it's taking
f of x and y
i don't know i mean it's look the most
common case is
something like join i mean i've used
this plenty of times to make the code
look nicer when i'm writing this
and honestly that doesn't look that bad
i mean it's just the tilde is just a
little bit obscure looking
and it could just be made a little bit
more elegant
and that would work fine
um
okay seth is pointing out on our live
stream that the main issue is is having
to parenthesize ampersands yeah i mean i
agree and that's an argument for
a matchfix version of function because
then you don't have to parenthesize
anything i mean you you know in the end
with that parenthesization you can't win
because that precedence is you know it's
boxed in by a bunch of other precedences
um
did you write an example maybe where you
have like a string of
you know i don't know a string of
compositions and then in the middle of
it you have one of these match fixed
functions i'm just wondering if it would
look
nicer than the
you know
that looks right now with ampersand okay
so you're saying compositions like this
yeah
and some of them will be operator forms
and some of them will be whatever they
are okay so let's say the one of these
is in the middle so this is a
a h of hash i mean it's not going to
look very good because the spacing is
wrong here right you can use square
brackets instead of rounded you know
brackets i think it might
not space so much
or never mind
i can make it a text cell
yeah yeah yeah
i think he has to do command nine to
make it look nicer as well but yeah
or like
in the text cell you can you can
style it as command nine and then at
least be the right font and stuff
okay but anyway this
i don't think this looks obviously bad i
think it looks rather nice actually
yeah i mean if we
and i mean especially with our auto
closing mechanism
having a composite there is not as
painful as it once was because that auto
closes
right you don't have to type
and the ability of one of these things
to auto close in the right place is
going to be much higher by by being a
a
composite character
um
well i kind of agree we should look at
this what is the right form though
is it this is it bracket vertical bar or
what
anybody going to open in
i mean are there any symbols that are
actually like you know right now we use
ampersand i argue ampersand has really
nothing to do with functions
are there any symbols that do have
something to do with functions that
could be used brackets
well sure i mean brackets are also just
generally used for match fix things so i
think brackets are fine
i think we have to have pair something
that pairs and that we basically got
angle brackets
scribe brackets braces and idle brands
yeah
i think angle brackets probably a bit
too big well i guess for the things that
i go back
but i mean i think i would kind of favor
uh the parenthesis case i think it's
more because i think the bracket case is
kind of the wrong way around because
this thing is making something
that can have a bracket after it
yeah the only thing is that i feel like
parentheses are
and you're sort of trained to think that
parentheses are ugly
i mean that's why the parentheses with
an ampersand is ugly because if you
think about that that's that's one fewer
character anyway
just having parentheses in an ampersand
i know but it looks ugly because there's
parentheses
i'm not convinced but that's possible um
uh dan is commenting on live stream that
it should be a way to highlight what
expression is being bound by an
ampersand absolutely that was supposed
to make it into thirteen one but i
believe it did not
that's a user assistance thing
that's for
um
you know
this whole thing was supposed to
show
a temporary
uh
parenthesis here to indicate what's
going on that is that has
absolutely been intended for several
versions and is coming soon just turns
out to be harder to do than you might
think
um and that will certainly help prevent
that kind of mistake
all right i think we should explore this
i think we should explore the matchfix
function i think we should explore auto
beautification of hash and ampersand
um
the function lambda thing is amusing and
maybe is worth exploring
for people who want to make something
that is very lambda looking i don't know
what do people think about that
deafening silence of these possibilities
right now i'm thinking that the
having an additional character for hash
and for ampersand perhaps is my favorite
i'm thinking of the situation with and
when we do hash and hash
we get the the logical and i like that
because for for inputs it looks very
nice
so what are you talking about yes if you
do a and then escape
and escape
and and letters
b yeah right so so so that's something
else that passes to
to end and so if we had something for
heist and perhaps something that
typesets has a very little ampersand
that plays also the role of function
yeah but why not do it automatically i
mean we don't need to have a special
that can happen with the ligatures
mechanism that can happen automatically
when you just type the thing and it
becomes a function
but in a sense we want to
control when where we put the ampersand
it is the matter of what we put there
should be something
that
is the ampersand but typesets slightly
different
sure but but it can happen automatically
right you just as soon as you type the
ampersand it can format as some other
character
or a smaller ampersand or whatever else
your mechanism does
okay so that would
always be the case i was thinking about
something in which you can choose to do
that representation
like in and
no i think it would always be the case i
think it's what we want to do just like
dash greater than always does that okay
um
all right look can we please look into
this match fix thing can we look into
the auto beautification thing these
additional characters i don't know i
mean i i think it's a question of how
well we can get the auto beautification
to just work
that making sense i mean
you know
i don't know what what the choices are i
mean i think
dots and boxes and things are good
things where they are placeholders we
put something in there and we just have
to decorate it with legs so that it
looks like a hash sign a bit
and maybe maybe now that we have fonts
that you know we can by the time we can
do emoji we can do gray fonts so we can
do something where the box has
tentacles that are gray for example
that makes sense
so okay i think i think we're this topic
anything else on this topic
we haven't solved this but we've got
definite directions nick any got by the
comments on this
no i think that gives us a good baseline
i'll try checking in with
maybe john about it just to see what his
opinion on it is as well right
and i don't think we're going to have
time for much of this but um
uh
back to the first item danny yes okay
fine i just want to ask about this wfr
promotion efforts i mean as wfr expands
like for example
there's one recently added by brad this
nest wild graph function which i rather
like
and i think that's one we should
consider
and i'm just kind of wondering would
that be picked up automatically by the
procedure that you have or not
yeah i mean danny can maybe talk more
about the procedure but yeah we
basically do a regular polling of the
new functions they get evaluated and
then they go into a queue to get triaged
this is for example
oh go ahead i think the answer might be
not in that case though
um it would depend on whether we
recognized on the wfr end when we do the
assessments
whether it's very much akin to um
nest
was
what's the nest graph while or something
like that oh there is no nescar file
it's it's a nest wild graph
is a version of nest graph that doesn't
just go a fixed number of steps it has a
termination condition i got it okay so
it's yeah i i i did not know until brad
told me that we had a nest graph
if other people on the wfr team were
aware of that when we did the assessment
we might and we have not yet gotten to
this one in the assessments but you know
under different circumstances if no none
of us knew that we probably wouldn't
think to
promote it we would think well this is a
very niche function yeah even if it's a
good one right i understand i'm telling
you i think that one is useful yeah no
knowing that yes we will of course but
um you know put it forward
um but in general it's part of a bigger
picture that nick is working on but it's
just one particular case of that that i
think is useful
but anyway
okay
what are we talking about here
well a few things but i would say naming
the thing and
going back on the design to something
actually
um
you know sensible and not not crazy
because we we painted ourselves into two
or three different corners none of them
particularly close to one another
um okay so position logist tells you
simply the position
with varying degrees of of um
festooned you know with with
braces and so on right um
uh
the position of the largest element or
the position of the largest element by
something in a list
right and
um
there was a lot of controversy over the
uh nesting of the braces in part because
position
would seem to imply a position spec
and i'm thinking the more i you know and
i actually did implement all the
craziness at one point but i'm thinking
this isn't what we want what we want is
to just return the indices we want them
grouped
uh i think everybody agrees with that
you know so that the um
the the the different ranks are
separated
but uh other than that we don't want all
the nesting
that position would entail i think that
was a bad idea i think it sidetracked us
and i think this could be an actually
useful function it is useful i i do it
all the time i mean it's position of max
of whatever you know i write it a
million times
you know it's extract of well it's the
yes you know
it's the extract
well
no but you're not doing the extract
you're doing just the position i'm yeah
right
what i i guess i meant was it would be a
spec for an extract rather do i have it
right extract versus part yes you have
it right okay position returns us an
extract spec
right so what you're saying is that this
is more like an index
yes
yes indexed largest would would be
a a we have such a kind of worms because
we've got map indexed which actually
takes a position spec
and we've got this supplied headdress
okay does anybody have an idea here what
to do
because
go ahead
yeah i was going to say i think danny is
right in that when we initially looked
at this we wanted a pretty simple
function that was give me the position
of the max value
yeah that's what we want
which is basically what danny has
proposed with position first largest or
i know but that name is just not going
to make it
yeah um
i i sent email about this um
let's see uh in roughly uh a little over
a month ago
um and i i had some particular
um
possibilities to suggest if if you want
i can go
tell us what that just can you just show
them
um
show them uh let me share that or
no why don't you send them a chat it's
just a list of names uh
okay the names i can put in chat um
hold on
i mean the the key idea is just like we
have things like ranked max and so on
maybe we have
uh
i mean i don't know you know
i don't know what to write i mean the
other i mean one possibility is just to
leave the name alone
return a part spec rather than an
extract spec without the extra listing
one possibility is to go through all the
rigor mural with an optional argument
which is what we
have now and i don't like it i'm largest
okay
no
that's
simply not going to work
largest ranks indices
i don't get it i mean
argmax
list augments
yeah by analogy with arg max
no i understand the idea i mean that's
interesting because it gets us out of
the
box of um
right the one thing i didn't like about
it is that arg max itself mentions
position but well i think it's lower
case
yeah and it's a i think lower case use
not not
not the position function right because
it's giving
right some continuous position on the
real line but all right the other nice
thing about list argmax is that it makes
it very clear that this is a level one
thingy yes
yeah that's a good point but what about
this case here i mean this is
augmax is such an obscure name though
but i do like i like getting us out of
that box
i just worry that that
you know it just is a cognitive
jump you're reading a piece of code and
you know argmax is one of these things
you see
sort of it's you know machine learning
papers seem to be full of odd maxes
um
well optimization papers in general used
to be maybe still
why do they stop
i'm not sure they have maybe they just
stopped reading them
i don't know
i mean argmax was the thing that sort of
emerged about 15 years ago or something
as a thing you'd never seen it before
no no no it was in literature
going back more than 15 years yeah i'm
30 at least
in optimization
okay
we don't get to have an arg max buy and
that is really obscure
let's think
that's terrible
star just
um
what are the words the words the
description is
gives
the
index
of
the
see but it doesn't give the index gives
a list doesn't it because it's always it
doesn't know whether there's a single
largest
list max indices is another
permutation of these that i did not put
on here
but it it's it's not hard max at least
okay but but this
gives a list
of the indices
but then then is there some other
argument that says how many of them
yes so it's actually a list of lists
and why isn't it doing
take largest buy doesn't give a list of
lists it just puts them in the order
oh that's right however we don't have
the notion of separating ranks
we're not giving a number of ranks we're
we're just
giving a number of elements and why
aren't we doing that here
here are we giving a number of ranks
well i mean because if we do that then
we just have it it just boils down to
take largest
with um whatever goes to uh indices
this the functionality that i
implemented is actually something
different and it is not trivial to get
okay so we've also got things like i
mean communist is a good example
of something where we are where it has
an unexpected listification
i mean this is it's not self-evident but
something that will ask for the
you know
the position of the largest
you know
um
i mean this is the obvious name except
that it has the wrong number of braces
for that
to be honest yes that's the obvious name
yes and that one of one of the proposals
i had was go with that name
don't care about the bracing
especially since it's got another form
of of multi-bracing
you know
yeah
we have first position so perhaps what
we are looking for is our first position
largest
yeah except that the bracing is again
different because first position
right first position gives you one thing
it doesn't give you
something other than a uh extract spec
oh but look it's it's in a it's in
braces as well
exactly right because it gives you an
extract spec that is the full extract
spec for that position
right first position is basically first
of position with a little bit of
sugar around that
look the only name that anybody's ever
going to understand is position largest
and the fact that it has weird bracing
i mean it's got to have weird bracing
because of the multi-rank issue
i don't even know that i would consider
it weird
well fine maybe position largest is the
right thing a position largest so it's
position largest and then it's a count
of the ranks is that right
yes so sorry is it is it um
does this function work
like you know position takes a level
spec does this does this no deeper than
level one it does not
okay and what's the business
what's that say again
what what's the
objection to calling this index largest
because i think that's an
incomprehensible
name because i think that the word index
is one we haven't used consistently and
i think index largest
just
you know position is something people
understand because it's used all over
the place
and the fact that this returns something
with slightly different bracing it's
just pedantic to call it something
different i think
i'm fine with that argument i mean i did
propose indices largest but i
i don't think it's right yeah i think
position largest is the right thing
i'm concerned about
this
um
i mean the ranks thing is weird i i
unfortunately need to go i have another
live stream actually coming up um
uh
i think we should go with position
largest position logic
and try and work out how to put the
consequences of that
um
all right
sounds good everybody
all right
see you later